welcome to this video this is a blitz
game five minute on icc playing dexter
morgan and see some playing a 5 + h 5 I
mean whatever you can say about Dexter
in the TV show it's not already stupid
and a 5 + h 5 hmm ok let's see what
happens here I'm going to go with f5
opening opening up the position and she
definitely definitely does not want to
develop it seems let me check kenner I'm
already am taking on e6 orgy success
tempting taking on e6 then take on f7
it's not not clear that it's winning
really takes on e6 be takes e4 takes on
f7 and then I have a big double check on
e5 but I'm not sure that it wins yeah
this is this is a bit meek but certainly
enough to keep a big edge I'm just
threatening to take on g6 and play e5 um
yep now that sets the easiest way to do
it next move is e5
I'm going to get here is a complete
domination on the dark squares that will
be very tough for black to to play um
yeah he's using this pin I wonder can
you really castle maybe yeah I'm going
to attack g6 he really yeah I cannot
really defend the porn I guess he will
just castle and hope for the best and
yeah let's see yeah he's threatening
this discovered check of course so I
probably should move the night you know
let's just put it here d3 is ultimately
just a check
this is a new account by the way let's
let know it's got a couple of games
played okay let's get rid of this hopes
this profile um bishop age six and after
that he is resigning or not hmm i don't
i don't see how it defends this rook f7
i play 95 and this is a an overload just
just too many attacking pieces check
yeah that's a bit too much Queen f7
queen age seven everything hangs so
that's really really just winning um
let's see what is the quickest win after
can I sacrifice the Queen maybe after 95
Queen g7 or something like that probably
not maybe Luke f7 is probably working
yeah maybe he's just letting the clock
run down this would somewhat somehow fit
his MO to stay within the typical talk
of police procedurals resign I don't
know his son is actually resigning yeah
I'm okay well a five and h5 this is
really not recommended I just wanted to
get quickly at f7 which is a good idea
opening up the the whole thing very
quickly um yeah after that I think I
probably I can take but I wasn't really
sure something like this or this i don't
i don't mind this this chat here and I
wasn't totally sure if I'm winning I
actually have you know what I didn't
really say is that here I can just go
nite f7 which is quite enough I mean I'm
getting the rook and I have the attack
so um yeah and probably I don't know
where the queen is actually going like
here has Bishop g5 even yeah that's a
disaster but ok Bishop d3 is not much
worse i mean we look at this this is
just a win for white right the comp is
on plus plus 3 which is some quite quite
convincing
yeah i'm playing order all the computer
moves we're just not not difficult to do
here really I wondered after this if I
can do yeah I can do gap 7s is a cute
win check check check check mate that's
nice the comp of course esis immediately
I'm not sure if I would have would have
gone for that I mean it's it's within my
abilities to play with this stuff but
when you win with every move you should
be cautious with with those fancy ideas
so probably I would have done something
more prosaic yeah okay I hope you
enjoyed that thanks for watching